Kia ora, two weeks on from lockdown.
Just checking in with you and those in your
bubble to see that you're doing okay.
A few things to update you on.
Last week I  talked about the coming rates
installment, we understand that people
are facing an uncertain financial future.
If you have any concerns about paying
this, please be in touch with us. We have
many options that we can look at to
support you including deferral and we
welcome that opportunity to discuss that
with you and tailor a package directly
to you that will help you through this period.
Last week, Council's Emergency
Operations Center was stood up. The whole
purpose of this is to support people
through this time and connect you with
relevant organisations, so if there's
anyone that you know of that needs
support including yourself, please be in
contact with us our number is:
0800 965 468, as I say, we're here to help.
As Mayor and Councillors, we're concerned about the
rates for the coming years and we've
asked our staff, particularly in these
uncertain times, to have another look at
our budgets and identify where there can
be savings.  Next week we're having a
workshop, we will be discussing these
with staff and then in the coming weeks
expect to be able to communicate with
you our thinking.
We're coming into Easter, all I'd like to say to you is make sure that you enjoy the long
weekend. Take the opportunity to spend
that time with those in your bubble.
Connect with your families. Do stay calm,
please stay home, follow the rules,
be kind and take care of each other.
Happy Easter!